(Rires)
Les paresseux ressemblent étrangement aux Beatles.
Je suis particulièrement satisfaite de Paul.
Mais comme les Beatles, les paresseux sont extrêmement prospères.
Ils descendent d'une ancienne lignée de mammifères
et il y a eu des dizaines d'espèces,
y compris le Megatherium, qui faisait la taille d'un petit éléphant
et était l'un des rares animaux
assez grands pour manger des noyaux d'avocat entiers
et de les disséminer.
Alors... (Rires)
Certains ont déjà compris.
(Rires)
Cela veut dire que sans paresseux,
il n'y aurait peut-être pas aujourd'hui de tartines à l'avocat,
laissant les hipsters complètement dépourvus au petit-déjeuner.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Aujourd'hui, six espèces survivent et se divisent en deux groupes.
Vous avez vos bradypus, ou paresseux tridactyles,
c'étaient ceux avec les coupes des Beatles et le sourire de Mona Lisa.
Puis il y a les paresseux didactyles.
Ils ressemblent un peu plus
à un croisement entre un wookie et un cochon.
Ils vivent dans les jungles d'Amérique centrale et du Sud
et sont très féconds.
Une étude réalisée dans les années 70
dans une forêt tropicale panaméenne
a découvert que le paresseux était l'animal de grande taille
le plus abondant d'un point de vue numérique.
Ils représentaient un quart de la biomasse mammalienne.
C'est une très grande quantité de paresseux
et cela suggère qu'ils font les choses correctement.
Et si, au lieu de ridiculiser le paresseux car il est différent,
nous essayions plutôt d'apprendre de lui ?
Nous, les humains, sommes obsédés par la vitesse.
Être occupé est une distinction
et la commodité l'emporte sur la qualité dans notre quête du rapide.
Notre addiction à une vie rapide nous étouffe, nous et la planète.
Nous idolâtrons des animaux comme le guépard,
« la Ferrari du monde animal »,
capable de passer de zéro à 60 km/h en trois secondes.
Et alors ?
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Et alors ?
Les paresseux, de l'autre côté,
peuvent atteindre un tranquille cinq mètres par minute
avec le vent de dos.
(Rires)
Mais être rapide est coûteux.
Le guépard est rapide au détriment de sa force.
Il ne peut pas risquer de se battre
alors il perd une proie sur neuf
face à des prédateurs plus forts comme la hyène.
Pas étonnant qu'elle rie.
(Rires)
Le paresseux, d'autre part,
a adopté une approche plus furtive pour le dîner.
Il survit en capturant et en consommant
des feuilles statiques.
(Rires)
Mais les feuilles ne veulent pas plus être mangées qu'une antilope,
alors elles sont pleines de toxines et très difficiles à digérer.
Afin de les consommer,
le paresseux doit aussi devenir un athlète --
un athlète de la digestion.
(Rires)
L'arme secrète du paresseux est un estomac à quatre poches
et beaucoup de temps.
Il a le taux de digestion le plus lent chez les mammifères.
Cela peut lui prendre jusqu'à un mois pour digérer une seule feuille,
ce qui donne plein de temps à son foie pour transformer les toxines.
Les paresseux ne sont pas flemmards.
Non, ils sont occupés.
À digérer.
(Rires)
Oui, très occupés.
Il travaille dur, ce paresseux, il travaille très dur.
Bien sûr, les feuilles ont une faible valeur calorifique,
alors le paresseux a évolué pour dépenser aussi peu d'énergie que possible.
Il réalise environ 10% du travail d'un mammifère de taille similaire
et survit modestement avec 100 calories par jour,
grâce à des adaptations ingénieuses.
Le Bradypus, le paresseux tridactyle,
a plus de vertèbres cervicales que les autres mammifères,
y compris que la girafe.
Cela signifie qu'il peut tourner la tête à 270 degrés
et brouter tout autour de lui
sans avoir à prendre la peine de bouger son corps.
(Rires)
Cela veut également dire que, surprenamment, c'est un très bon nageur.
Le paresseux peut se glisser dans l'eau
trois fois plus vite qu'il ne se déplace à terre,
maintenu à flot par...
des gaz piégés en eux.
(Rires)
Alors --
Le paresseux est le seul animal connu qui n'a pas de flatulences.
Quand il a besoin d'expulser des gaz,
ils sont réabsorbés dans son sang
et expulsés oralement sous une forme de pet de bouche.
(Rires)
Renverser ainsi leur vie lui fait économiser plus d'énergie.
Il a un muscle squelettique deux fois moindre qu'un mammifère terrestre.
Il n'a pas tant de muscles extenseurs,
les muscles qui portent le poids,
au lieu de cela, il recourt à des muscles rétracteurs pour se traîner.
Il a de longues griffes crochues et une haute résistance à la fatigue,
alors il peut s'accrocher et pendre tel un heureux hamac poilu
pendant des heures.
Le paresseux peut presque tout faire dans cette position renversée.
Il dort, il mange, il accouche même ainsi.
Sa gorge et ses vaisseaux sanguins sont spécifiquement adaptés
à pomper du sang et avaler de la nourriture
contre la gravité.
Il a des sections collantes sur ses côtes
qui empêchent son énorme estomac d'écraser ses poumons.
Sa fourrure pousse dans la direction opposée
pour qu'il puisse égoutter après une pluie tropicale.
Le seul problème est que si vous retournez un paresseux,
la gravité lui ôte sa dignité.
Public : Ohhhhhh.
Il ne peut pas se tenir droit.
Il traîne son corps tel un alpiniste sur une surface plane.
Ce doit être pour cela que les premiers explorateurs comme Valdès
les dénigraient tant
car ils observaient les paresseux à l'envers et en dehors de leur contexte.
J'ai passé de nombreuses heures hypnotisée par des paresseux en déplacement.
Le manque de muscles n'a pas entravé leur force ou leur agilité.
Les maîtres zen de la nature et des mouvements doux
comme « Le Lac des cygnes » au ralenti --
(Rires)
avec un contrôle abdominal digne d'un maître du tai chi.
Celui-ci s'est endormi en mouvement, ce qui n'est pas rare.
(Rires)
Mais vous devez vous demander :
comment un sac ballant de feuilles en digestion évite-t-il d'être mangé ?
Bonne question.
Voici l'un des principaux prédateurs du paresseux.
C'est la harpie féroce.
Elle peut voler à des vitesses allant jusqu'à 80km/h,
à des griffes de la taille de celles d'un grizzly,
une vision perçante
et cet anneau de plume concentre le son
pour qu'elle puisse entendre le moindre bruissement de feuilles.
Le paresseux, d'un autre côté, a une mauvaise ouïe, une mauvaise vue
et fuir le danger n'est clairement pas une option.
Il survit en portant une cape d'invisibilité
digne de Harry Potter.
Son pelage a des rainures qui attirent l'humidité
et agissent comme de petits jardins hydroponiques pour les algues
et attirent également tout un tas d'invertébrés.
Le paresseux est son propre écosystème lent et miniature.
Il ne fait qu'un avec l'arbre.
Nous pensons que ses mouvements sont si lents
qu'ils passent sous le radar de la monstrueuse harpie
pendant qu'elle vole au-dessus de la canopée,
à la recherche d'action.
Le paresseux est un ninja furtif
et il quitte rarement la sécurité de la canopée --
à part pour déféquer,
ce qu'il fait environ une fois par semaine au pied d'un arbre.
Ce comportement risqué et énergétique a longtemps été un mystère
et il y a beaucoup de théories quant à pourquoi il agit ainsi.
Mais je pense qu'il laisse des messages odorants subreptices
à ses partenaires potentiels.
Car le paresseux est généralement une créature silencieuse et solitaire,
à part quand la femelle est en chaleur.
Elle montera en haut d'un arbre et criera à la relation sexuelle.
Un ré.
(Rires)
Vous ne me croyez pas ?
(Cri de paresseux)
Ré.
Cette note uniquement attirera l'attention du mâle.
Cela imite le son du tyran quiquivi.
La femelle demeure à couvert,
même quand elle appelle à pleins poumons à des relations sexuelles.
Son appel clandestin à un plan cul est transmis à des kilomètres à la ronde
et les mâles feront un lent chemin vers elle.
(Rires)
Je pense que les messages odorants dans ses excréments
aideront à envoyer Roméo en haut du bon arbre
afin qu'il ne gaspille pas sa précieuse énergie
à escalader le mauvais arbre.
D'ailleurs, le sexe est la seule chose que les paresseux font rapidement.
Je les ai vus dans la nature
et cela est terminé en l'espace de quelque secondes.
Pourquoi gaspiller une précieuse énergie,
surtout après un tel périple ?
(Rires)
Contrairement à d'autres mammifères,
le paresseux ne perd pas de temps
à maintenir une température corporelle constante.
L'énergie du soleil est gratuite,
alors il se prélasse au soleil tel un lézard
et porte un manteau exceptionnellement épais pour les tropiques
pour conserver cette chaleur.
Le paresseux a un métabolisme incroyablement lent.
Nous pensons que cela pourrait être l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles il se remet de blessures
qui tueraient la plupart des animaux.
Ce paresseux s'est remis d'une double amputation
et j'ai vu des paresseux ayant réussi à survivre
à une électrocution par des lignes à haute tension.
Nous pensons qu'un métabolisme lent pourrait être la clé
pour survivre à une extinction.
Des chercheurs de l'université du Kansas qui étudiaient les mollusques
ont découvert qu'un métabolisme élevé prédisait quelles espèces de mollusques
avaient disparu.
Le paresseux est sur cette planète sous une forme ou une autre
depuis plus de 40 millions d'années.
Le secret de sa réussite est sa nature paresseuse.
C'est une icône de l'économie d'énergie.
J'ai fondé la Société d'appréciation du paresseux
pour promouvoir et protéger sa vie lente, stable et durable.
Je suis d'une nature dynamique.
Vous avez dû le deviner.
Le paresseux m'a beaucoup appris sur comment ralentir.
Je pense que cela bénéficierait à la planète
si nous adoptions un peu leur rythme de vie.
Et si nous embrassions tous le paresseux en nous
en ralentissant,
en étant plus attentifs,
en réduisant le gaspillage lié à des commodités,
en économisant notre énergie,
en recyclant de façon créative
et en renouant avec la nature.
Autrement, j'ai peur
que ce soit nous, les êtres humains, qui nous avérerons être
« l'animal le plus stupide que l'on puisse trouver dans le monde ».
Merci beaucoup.
Que la force du paresseux soit avec vous !
(Applaudissements)